hi my name's and I am seven years old
and today I'm gonna have to have my cool
hi there I'm Hannah and I'm Matthew nice
to meet you
so we have a question for you if you
were a monster what would you eat look
any deeper little meat buzzes gonna be a
ball I don't know what I can do for that
if we pose our eyeballs
what's the spaghetti is worms look I am
a mother I don't have time for guessing
games
you just got to tell me what you want
and I will serve it up what would it be
though of the noodles be it's something
green grass yes okay this sauce is gonna
be pizza hey Connie
pinky pinky pink sauce pink I could do
some kind of like penne alla vodka but
I'm not gonna serve alcohol to a kiss
you draw this for us no goo I got the
bowl it's gonna be grass with the green
looks great on the picture but I don't
think that actually applies to good food
have you ever tried graphs in real life
before
I've eaten grass I used to eat grass and
sand when I was a kid would you have
been my friend if you saw me eating
grass and sand oh she's the cutest
fricking kid I've ever seen and what
color eyes are they no pink guys I chose
the job I'm up good monsters eat
eyeballs it's pink your favorite color
yes I can tell you got pink pink it is
the sauce go on top of the eyeballs is a
bad surprise
there are so many games with this kid oh
yeah okay please let it not be like
another eyeball inside of an eyeball
okay so this is beautiful do you think
that Hannah and I can make this for you
yes okay thank you
I need it so here's my plan
I know Matthew is going to go savory so
I'm gonna make a green ice cream
spaghetti with red cake
truffles coated in pink candy melts with
some decoration on top to make them look
like eyeballs and then for her pink
sauce I'm just gonna do a very simple
strawberry syrup okay so here is my plan
I'm gonna make a ring of classic
spaghetti with marinara sauce and then
I'm going to make eyeball meatballs with
cheese in the center and olives for the
pupils and then I'm gonna put some herbs
as the grass awesome Parmesan cheese and
some sort of pink alfredo sauce in the
center for contrast I'm starting with a
fresh box of take em right off the bat
I'm a little bit of a mess and I'm a
little bit nervous so I'm following
these instructions doing a great job
perfectly done box starting with some
olive oil and some butter in my pot to
cook my onions and garlic you'd like
Shafi I'm ma mère see I hate adding food
coloring to stuff like that's my kind of
anti mom stance I'm gonna get these into
the oven and turn on the ice cream
Hannah mentioned ice cream I was floored
there's no way I would have told them to
do that Hannah is ambitious right now
I'm just kind of like sauteing the
onions until they get kind of
caramelized and soft and then I'm gonna
add in tomato paste to do a technique
kind of called pin saj and that's not
had like some nuance to the marinara
sauce I'm listening to Matthew give us
step by step of his recipe and it's like
all these long words I don't understand
he's like Martha Stewart my sauce is a
nuanced strawberry compote water mix a
little water I don't know how much so
I'm just gonna add it okay so I'm gonna
start mixing my meatballs to make the
eyeball meatballs so I have three pounds
of ground beef here I'm going to add
different spices and some bread crumbs
and some eggs I'm gonna add ricotta it's
like my secret ingredients so I'm gonna
try something truly evil instead of
using green food coloring I'm gonna see
if I can color the ice cream with the
kale adding kale to ice cream is an A+
mom move but I'm not sure if an Iowa
like this yeah maybe this is
big parenting fun hashtag k-y scream
hashtag tricking my kids so now I'm
gonna add a little bit of these sauteed
onion for the eyeballs here a tiny
little mozzarella ball that I'm gonna
put into the meatballs
so off to the oven I go and while those
bake I'm gonna start boiling my pasta
and this pasta is gonna cook for about
10 minutes I'm gonna add herbs and my
tomato paste and tomato sauce to my
onion I've made marinara sauce and
meatballs literally thousands of times
in my life but I don't know if it'll
taste like spaghetti she's used to so
another trick I saw on the internet you
take an empty can and you hook holes in
it with a hammer and nails and then you
put your ice cream in and you can push
it through and it makes spaghetti it
looks very easy on the video oh okay
looks good so now I'm gonna add the
herbs and the like pureed tomatoes to
make a sauce so I'm adding a little bit
of chili flakes not too much and some
parsley dried basil some more two bay
leaves and then this will just simmer so
usually we take pops you mix a tub of
frosting but I think I'm gonna get some
cream cheese out of the fridge too and
you like the mixture of cream cheese and
frosting okay so this is nice and mixed
in and then I have these pink candy melt
to coat the outside your meatballs smell
incredible
thank you I have a nice crowd you wanna
try it yeah I gotta see what I'm up
against
[Music]
there okay the olives are gonna kind of
be like the pupils of the eye it
couldn't have come out better I don't
like all is that I don't want them
but on links in my thing I'm just doing
some various sized cake pops
so the candy melt that I use to dip
these cake pops is just not working for
me it's not smooth it's lumpy it's too
thick I am struggling so hard to get
some around a meatball shaped cake pop
I'm making like you know Roux right now
and a roux is roughly about equal parts
fat and flour so I just took raw beets
and pureed it let's start with that
amount and I can kind of add more as I
go but oh right that's cool
so I'm piping the pupils on the cake
pops and it's going well I'm getting
kind of like the outline of the iris and
then the pupil and then I step back and
look at it holistically and it did not
turn out the way I thought they look
like oops
Oh
[Music]
honest opinion Matthew more boob or less
boob I mean I haven't seen too many blue
with in my life so I'm going to chop
some herbs chives parsley and basil to
put the grass on top I'm going to put
some sauce in the pan pasta and some
cheese Wow make a little bit of like a
well in the center okay so for
decorating this second round of cake
pops I just coated it in white chocolate
that I mixed a bunch of coconut oil into
they stayed nice and round they're not
all lumpy and then I have these little
pink rock candies and I'm gonna make
them like the iris of the eye so it's a
pink eye it's just not a Boop this makes
me feel happy look at that so second
round of eyeballs are looking amazing
everything I learned from my mistakes is
now turning into a success so now I'm
putting on the eyeball meatballs I'm
going to pour this beet Alfredo into the
well of my little eyeball grass nest and
then I'll put a little bit of Parmesan
cheese over the top I'm done I know I
cooked the best food I could today I
just hope it's something that Ania will
love so this is my whole can let's see
oh god I'm not strong you know okay well
it's definitely working it's just very
hard to do so I see Hannah she's like
hacking away at this can and I'm like
there has to be a better way I gotta
help her out I thought you were
struggling with the can thing if you use
this I think you can leave the ice cream
out better and I won't have to struggle
with my jar in the can okay this is
amazing thank you so let's see how this
ricer works Oh Shh yeah I can't believe
how well that worked
seriously it was like night and day it
was so easy and so amazing tada
it was a journey we finally got done and
I think we did a good job good job
at this point I've just gone through an
entire emotional rollercoaster
I took her drawing that was very literal
and I made a very abstract
interpretation all I know is that I did
not put cakepop boobs on this plate so
I'm feeling great about my dish I have
the perfect spaghetti the marinara sauce
is the meatballs that turned out
perfectly
I think Anaya is gonna be impressed with
how it looks like her dish but how it
still reminds her of all gone that looks
like something that Amman to me yes
that's what I was going for
[Music]
it keeps good if you think my mom and my
dad was spaghetti
she said it reminds her of how her mom
and her grandmother made it I can't do
better than that
hmm good you like yogurt oh I think I
know what this is it's cheese hmm
probably apart
is the gate to my sister baby cries the
pink sauce when I got my drawing that's
high speed well then what's this pink
stuff it's hard and show us this the
back stops a little hard and now when
I'm trying to spaghetti
this is ice cream ice cream do you
immediately said vanilla so didn't
notice the tail hi boss
you think it'll cook but I want to find
out what the pink stuff is the pink
stuff is crunchy its jack life worth
they were caught in the candy and I said
if we were punished us up with a cupcake
I'm a dead put the fire mr. black frosty
so she tasted everything seems like she
liked all of it so going into this
deciding round I think either one is
fair game and I don't an ayah I heard
you say you liked both dishes a lot
which way it is kind of like you had
your dinner and then you had your
dessert so which one was your favorite
okay
spaghetti yeah with me I mean I'm not
surprised he deserved it
I'm glad you liked it
but we're glad you enjoyed fall oh my
god death match you choose your prize oh
my god Anaya Wow hannah and her ice
cream I tried it was delicious she did a
great job the end of day I'm really glad
that I came out on top if you want to
win you keep your eyes on the prize or I
mean I guess a bowl full of eyes on the
prize
[Music]
you
[Music]